[Music]
2022 corporate chess league spring
season
my name is caleb denby and i'm super
excited to be giving you the commentary
over tonight's games uh it's an exciting
night uh if you just finished watching
the spring chess classic don't worry
this is just as exciting although the
the level of play might be down just a
little bit from that of ilia nizhnik and
sam savion the time control though
almost the same it's game in 10 minutes
no two second increment uh like we saw
in the tie breaks that last event
and it's a pretty exciting night we've
got a lot of great teams here tonight i
think one more team than that first week
we've got enterprise returning along
with edward jones we have ascension we
have darty and i believe bayer is making
their season debut here tonight so let's
see what's going on in these games we
already actually have a result here but
i'm interested in looking at this
enterprise versus ascension matchup that
we've got for round number one here so
for that we're going to take a look at
kamikaze knight on board one
uh playing for enterprise up against
frank t tan
so what's going on in in this position
let's let's take a look here
so right off the bat i'm i'm seeing that
somebody's in check but
in return black seems to be attacking a
lot of things here so i'm kind of
curious what happens if if g6 gets
played looks like this bishop's attacked
looks like this queen's attacked there's
a knight f6 check but i can capture that
and then if you take back your queen
hangs i don't know looks like black
might be winning a piece here let's
let's see how this happened let's let's
go back to the stop back to the start so
we had a slav defense uh black did go
ahead and take on c4 tried to hold on to
the pawn we got a fiance so far so
normal how did we get to this crazy
position
okay so 95 takes takes queen d7
and yeah black just decided not to
develop and get castled right away and
went for this strange-looking f6 move so
much more normal would just be to play
bishop e7 and develop your pieces but
instead we're ending up here and we'll
see if frank
has the uh has the guts to play this
move g6 i'm not sure it's going to work
out well for white to be honest
a lot of times
players will be tempted to try and
overly punish their opponents when they
play things like f6 early on in the
opening
but a lot of the times it's best just to
play normal chess and let the weaknesses
speak for themselves a little bit later
on
okay we do see kamikaze knight's idea
though he does sacrifice his knight on
f6 then has this nice move queen g5 now
this knight is going to be pinned to the
rook on h8
and attached twice so
uh it's all
all under control for kamikaze knight
all under control never in doubt so at
the end of the day it looks like white
is going to have picked up a pawn here
picked up the f6 pawn
black was up a pawn to begin with but
this f6 pawn does leave quite a lot of
weaknesses around black king and this
bishop is very much inferior to this
bishop on g2 so
after that little tactical flurry uh g6
knight f6 and then queen g5 it looks
like white is on the better side of
things here
um yeah white doesn't even really need
to play for checkmate although that's
something that they can do you know h5
is somewhat tempting but at the end of
the day this bishop is really just going
to be a much worse piece than this one
this e6 pawn is going to be weak the e5
square is available for white's pieces
all good things going on here for
kamikaze knight
so with that let's check in on board two
which was pendulum against maurice gp
looks like we also have a result here
kendalum picking up the win for
enterprise
and then where was this s gilmore game
against 21 gigawatts it looks like in
that first game that already is finished
s gilmore picked up the win that's one
point for ascension in one point for
enterprise so far
and then i believe the board four game
has not yet gotten underway that would
be oak ave versus uh nirvan bungley but
i haven't been able to follow either
player not sure what's going on on that
board but looks like they they have not
been able to start their game so still
anybody's match here they're tied one to
one so far it looks like
let's keep following this game looks
like
frank is trying to double up on the f
file make use of this missing f pawn
and we get this nice e4 move by by
kamikaze knight okay
so big decisions being made big
decisions being made with e4 you do sort
of stunt your own bishop but it is gonna
take away some squares from from black
as well you see that rook on f5 had to
retreat back to f6
and yeah now just h5 so
i don't know how i feel about uh about
what kamikaze knight's doing here i
believe that's that's john boyer i keep
calling him kamikaze knights that's just
the name on on chess.com i believe that
is john and we do see now e5 okay so the
strike can come back to f5 but maybe
john has some devious intentions of
bishop e4 at some moment so for example
if you do go rook f5 i might take on g6
take on g6 play bishop e4 and i'm not
entirely certain how you are going to
defend this pawn
and in fact i think the same issue is
going to exist in this position we can
just take
take
bishop e4 and this pawn is is
indefensible so
looks like things are in fact going to
be working out for john taking away this
f6 square made it very difficult to
defend this weakness and looks like this
is it's going to go his way
uh so let's check back in on that board
too then
with pendulum versus maurice gp maurice
definitely needs to uh to come back in
order for ascension to stay in this
match here although again board 4 has
not yet started so
um that that could definitely definitely
change some things depending on if
there's a double forfeit on that board
for uh board 4 match up
okay queen back to c7 now
and what's going on in this position
looks like we have some kind of caro
khan
cairo exchange black was able to develop
the bishop outside the pawn chain
and in return white got a little bit of
pressure against this b-pawn and now you
see this move queen to a3 okay so
maurice is trying to make castling a
little bit difficult for black here
i'm not entirely certain that this is
all that dangerous though we can play
queen e7 pretty much whenever we want
it's not a bad move it contests the
queens
uh it contests white's queen and if the
queens come off the board
there's very little danger for black in
these positions
that being said white is always going to
be super solid here you see this pawn on
a4 is preventing this b5 advance black
of course would love to play a minority
attack here go b5 b4
try and create some weaknesses on this
queen side not going to be so easy with
this pawn on a4
okay h5 does not make a lot of sense to
me i don't know
uh what black has in mind here i guess
they're they're thinking you know
someday they want to do some fishing
pole stuff go after this king uh h4h3
type type of ideas but
the kingside attack feels like the the
wrong way to go here we just want to
finish your development we want to get
castled and black's play usually comes
on the queen side in these positions you
want to use this open c file
maybe plant a knight on c4 for example
h5h4h3 makes sense a lot of the time but
i don't think it makes sense here uh
white can also be capturing this this
bishop
this rook opposite this king just leaves
me with a deep sense of unease
i'm a little bit anxious about leaving
this rook opposite my king it makes my
d-pawn a little bit weak and if things
ever open up right if c4 ever gets
played for example
black is going to have a lot of
questions to answer right castles is
illegal and if the e-file is going to
get opened then you're in big big
trouble big big trouble
so kendallum
seems to have a solid position at first
glance but the more you look at it the
more uncertain things become
okay g3 responding to the h3 threat and
now kendalum is going to be able to take
off that knight on e5 uh if i'm white
i'm probably thinking i want to take
this back with the rook keep this e file
open keep that pressure on
he does choose to take back with the
pawn instead
so this is nice because it gains a tempo
against the knight but i think knight d7
is a very comfortable move for for black
we're attacking this pawn on e5 and now
queen to c5 is going to be very natural
even knight to c5 is going to allow
king's side castles
and i don't think that that white is
going to be able to capitalize on this
king being stuck in the center anymore
with rook takes again i think the c4
break was a really nice idea you want to
look to open things up when your
opponent's king is stuck in the center
but no such luck anymore now the e-file
is shut and things will stay closed
really competitive fight here though i
kind of want to stay with this game just
to give you the result here um kamikaze
knight did end up winning although
the g6 pun survived somehow very strange
i kind of want to know how that happened
how did this g6 pump survive oh black
just sacrificed the exchange to defend
the pawn yeah
so not so fun down the exchange and then
oh wow we actually had a blunder of the
queen wow tough tough for frank
okay let's stick with this though we got
knight to d7 and maurice is carefully
considering
uh their options here maurice actually
the rating favorite in this case
interestingly enough
uh so kendallum actually scored an upset
win in the first round
uh so with that
i believe the score in the match now is
two for enterprise and one for ascension
and again that that board four just a
huge question mark there not sure what's
going on
um let's see if i can actually pull that
game up now i wasn't able to pull it up
earlier
see if nirvan was able to connect or not
and it looks like their their game is
underway so board 4 underway they will
not have any forfeits in this match
always good news and we tuned in just in
time to see disaster for nirvan oak ave
coming after the king winning the queen
the es6 pawn was hanging with check rook
d1 also going to be very devastating um
looks like oak ave is going to get this
done for ascension and if he does get
that done for ascension we've got a very
competitive match that would be two to
two uh after this first round here two
to two
ooh some some tactics are afoot in this
maurice uh pendulum game so f3 played
attacking this bishop pendulum thinks he
spotted an in-between move with knight
takes e5 now if white is going to
capture on g4 of course the bishop on d3
will hang and that's what we see i also
wanted to point out that if you thought
you could take on e5 take on e5 take on
g4 winning um sorry two pieces for the
rook not so fast i have queen e3 check
in the end and you are going to lose one
extra minor piece
so fg4 may be the best that white could
do but now after knight takes d3 it is
gonna be black winning a pawn here we
get rookie three knight back to e5
rookie one and this is the game position
and yeah pendulum continues to play with
fire uh continues to play with fire with
this king in the center i would have
been i would have been playing queen to
c5 as quickly as i could uh get these
queens off the board now that i have a
material edge
and just make sure my king gets to
safety
so yeah queen c5 here is is a really
really just nice simplifying move make
sure that i don't get into any trouble
although after takes takes
you know maybe i'm i'm speaking out a
turn here b4 could be a problem when uh
white is making use of this uh
this pin down the e file the d pawn is
actually under threat
can we get queen b6 instead by pendulum
looking to make use of this knight
rook d4 is necessary
by by white to block off this diagonal
and complicated stuff still definitely
still complex
so the question is whose king is going
to be weaker i almost want to go totally
crazy play e5 here e5 f6 king f7 just to
get my king to somewhere uh slightly
more reasonable even f6 king f7
immediately my queen defends laterally
and you cannot move this rook to take
either my knight or the pawn due to the
pin
um
the pin on the king
yeah king d7 instead definitely not
going to be quite as safe as the f7
square
i don't know i don't know what's going
to happen in this game to be honest with
you
black is definitely up a couple pawns
but this king in the center like i've
been harping on it all game here but the
king in the center is
not so comfortable not so comfortable
so i still think we need to play this f6
move we have to get these squares under
control and we we really want to be
pushing pushing e5
okay rook he8 instead um
okay i guess this is also playable but
uh
i i mean i i want my king over here my
king would feel so much better a little
bit further out of the path of these
rooks
yeah now king to f1 uh white has
defended the h2 pawn
and with this the rook is unpinned able
to challenge this knight over here on on
g4 and if this knight moves out of the
way the knight to e5 check is going to
come in and the king is going to have to
continue continue to run
continue
the king run so i guess we have to play
net h6 and after knight e5 we just we
just keep on trucking just keep on
moving out of the way try to hide our
king on
a8 maybe this is possible maybe
ooh e5 but this rook can move this
rook's not pinned anymore
that's going to be a knight
that's just going to be a knight
rook takes g4 rooks moves sideways okay
nobody knows about rooks moving sideways
i i continue to make this bold claim
that the hardest rule in all of chess is
pieces moving sideways for whatever
reason my brain just cannot handle
especially queens moving sideways but
even rooks moving sideways sometimes
tough just not used to seeing these long
lateral swings across the board
very common
blunders that just get get missed
instead though maurice is picking up a
couple pawns going to probably level the
material counts maybe black is going to
be able to to keep one extra pawn
and this this game remains competitive
definitely remains competitive
all right let's check back in on board
one they're uh well underway into the
second game
uh frank
uh lost his first game to kamikaze
knights in sort of unfortunate style
there we saw some
tactics early on
but uh
they worked out in kamikaze night's
favor
okay here it looks like uh john boyer
kamikaze knight does have this nice
looking d4 pawn although with knight d5
he is daring uh just daring frank to
capture this guy i guess the idea is
that black is going to be getting the c2
pawn in return
looks reasonable enough so
the d4 pawn a strong central pawn but
sometimes it can be a little bit weak
it's a little bit overextended it has no
other pawns that are able to defend it
so this idea of trading it off for the
c2 pawn
uh not the most ridiculous thing i've
ever seen
definitely not the most ridiculous
um we'll leave them to it though i'm i'm
still curious about this game the action
is still ongoing here with maurice
versus kendalum
let's see what we've got going on
let's see what's going on here
uh by the way let me actually pull up my
chat room here i don't think i
had a chance to do this prior to the
show so let's see what you guys have to
say
in the chat
all right looks like it's just alex in
the chat good luck to alex
he says hey says who maybe i said
something
rude to alex i don't remember but says
me that's who says says me
okay rook back to c7 and
uh after those wild complications the
black king is finally safe the white
king is reasonably safe and black is a
pawn to the good
so we'll see if pendulum is able to
accurately handle this end game
um honestly this looks pretty tough to
actually win
with black you can play some f5 move
here
some f5 move to keep everything together
you don't really want to step back to h6
uh because then your h pawn is going to
die after rook h4 um i also wanted to
point out that white is firmly in
control over this uh
this open d file which is going to make
things a little bit tricky for black to
[Music]
try to get active he really has to just
focus on these central pawns and start
rolling them down the board
now if this rook retreats back along the
e file we are going to have to play rook
c to e7 to defend this guy enough times
we would like to play e4 but i'm not so
comfortable doing that because now this
pawn on f5 ends up a little bit weak
although maybe with the tempe
everything is going to work out like e4
the knight moves to d4 we go g6
um and everything stays together
the clocks are starting to run low
are starting to run low in this match
so
look out for for the pace to increase
here
again maurice really needs to win this
game for ascension he he again is the
rating favorite on board two here i
don't think ascension is the rating
favorite in many in many places against
enterprise so they they need to score
points where they do have that that lead
we do see e4 kicking the knight
although i'm just now realizing
that uh rook takes on f5 was definitely
possible here this rook on e8
just undefended
sorry excuse me so because of that
undefended rook uh e takes f3 not going
to be playable
this was missed though so now black does
have time to defend this f5 pawn
keep it keep it all together keep it
safe
never mind king c8 f5 was hanging h3 was
also hanging i really would have
preferred to take this f5 pawn this is
the scary pawn it defends the protected
past pawn on e4 so that was the one that
i think white should have captured but
knight takes h3 also playable
material is now even black did not
realize he needed to defend this pawn
last turn and he still does not realize
he needs to defend this pawn okay and
white still doesn't realize that they
can take it rook's moving sideways man
what what did i tell you rook's moving
sideways impossible rule it's just
impossible to uh to remember how the
rooks move
just a minute 30 left now for maurice
and with the fp f5 pawn alive i
definitely have to prefer the black
pieces here that e4 pawn just looks a
little bit intimidating
um as black i probably want to keep this
knight on the board i want to go back to
e5 look at squares like f3 start to make
some threats uh maybe against the queen
side might see four ideas
instead this knight comes back to f6
which i think is is just going to be a
worse square
black has the right idea though with
getting the king involved we want to
come up the board here and just help
support our pawns start pushing them
down the board
and
make white's life very very difficult
white's trying to set up a little bit of
a blockade it looks like on e3 but that
blockade can be broken once we get f5 uh
f5 f4 in maybe with g5 included
uh okay rook to d7 and
white can attack this f5 pawn for a
third time will it be defended this time
it will finally g6 i love g6 you just
want to shore up the pawn structure here
make sure everything is safe
can we get king c7 rather than king to
e7 not sure why the king is running to
the queen side here i would rather have
it more in the center where i can
support my pawns start rolling them down
the board
instead king c6 and this is a blunder
this is just a blunder knight e5 knight
e5 and the rook dies okay exchange up
now for maurice
exchange up
will he be able to use it nate d3 is
check and picks up a pawn but it's the
g6 pawn also hanging
okay so g5 instead but now rook d5 yeah
very very nasty stuff the f5 pawn hangs
and things are things are going downhill
things are going downhill very very
quickly knights just not good pieces not
good pieces compared to the rook
all right with that i'm tentatively
going to say that maurice is firmly in
control of this game and will likely go
on to win
he trades off the rook for the night in
order to queen his pawn as quickly as
possible and yeah that's gonna do it so
huge back and forth game there but it
looks like maurice is gonna be able to
level uh the score against kendalum that
brings the match score here to one to
one
uh one for pendulum one for maurice
and what does that do for the overall
score well kamikaze knight won on board
one in round one let's see how he's
doing in round two while i tally the
totals
um
we see pendulum and maurice splits 21
gigawatts and s gilmore also split on
board three so it comes down to board
one and board four uh right now kamikaze
knight is up one zip on board one but
oak ave is up one zip on board four so
we have a tied match we have an absolute
tied match
uh with just two games left
so these games count for a lot remember
the winner of each match gets 10
additional points for the grand prix
and that's what these players are
playing for it's a grand prix in the
regular season and then uh
whoever has the
four the four highest scoring teams in
the regular season will advance to the
playoffs so those 10 extra points are
going to count for a lot actually i
light it's 20 extra points i always do
this you get 10 points for a tie 20 full
points for winning a match so that is is
really where the money is
uh here it looks like a pretty good
position for black as far as the pieces
are concerned although
white is technically up a pawn and that
might be the the saving grace here
so this knight definitely dominates this
bishop on c1 and white has a lot of
weaknesses to keep track of
but the good news is
white has this extra pawn and so if one
of these weaknesses does fall
then white will not be down material at
the very least although it is getting
quite difficult to sort of play anything
with white
if i had the white pieces here i really
would have seriously considered going
bishop c3 this move might end up losing
a pawn back
depending on how the tactics work out
but i feel like you do just have to give
up a pawn here in order to to activate
your pieces a little bit
instead we get this b3 idea and now
queen to c3 keeps the pressure on
although bishop a3 is is check and is
sort of activating now maybe bishop a3
was was frank's idea all along
yeah bishop a3 played the king just
steps out of the way
and bishop d6 okay active pieces now the
bishop found a way to to get active the
knight definitely still the superior
minor piece oh my goodness just queen's
moving sideways again
things moving sideways uh the eternal
struggle and this is actually not just a
pawn this is checkmate so kamikaze
knight out of nowhere knight takes f4
just secures the victory in this game
easy peasy
so what does that mean what does that
mean for the match that means that
enterprise is up one point with just one
game remaining so where is that last
game
where is that last game i've lost it
i've lost the last game
ah here it is in nirvan actually this
game is over as well nirvan comes back
in the second round to win as well and
with that win enterprise has secured
match victory against ascension they
needed every point that they got but
they did get there in the end they did
get there in the end so that enterprise
wins their match against ascension
scoring those 20 extra points towards
the grand prix
it looks like edward jones has also
a very very nearly secured match victory
alex skirford winning both his games on
board three puts them
firmly in the lead we've got justini
linguini still playing on board one uh
so they just need another half point to
secure victory bayer has to win all
remaining three games in order to tie
the match edward jones just needs a half
point somewhere just they need a point
somewhere
uh so let's see justine linguini with
the black pieces here
it feels like white should be checkmated
somehow but
uh the question is how that's always the
question
so if queen h1 check there is knight to
g1 to defense so that's not going to be
good enough
uh it looks like
what does it look like there's like nike
three ideas
it doesn't really seem to be getting the
job done either
um
and what's the material count it looks
like black sacrificed in exchange to get
this attack going so
if white or sorry if black can't find
anything here they will just be down the
exchange
in the long run
maybe knight takes f2 or something but
queen takes f5
i guess is taking a piece back and and
threatening some checkmates with bishop
e6 we have seven ideas
maybe it's just not working for justini
maybe it's just not working out here
it's tough
very very tough
so if uh mc nick jm
is able to win this game
then
uh bayer keeps their hopes of tying the
match alive
that would also mean that fishers of men
uh would have to lose this game against
vindy so let's see how this is going
and while vindi uh out rated by like 500
points i don't know if 1200 is actually
accurate for his rating but uh assuming
it is outraged by a ton
but just up a clean knight just up a
full piece against fishers of men
so
if vindy is also able to win then that
just leaves me kez against nmc gin
which is down here if nmc uh g-i-n-n
however you pronounce that is able to
win this game
uh and
bayer does win on those top two boards
as well then that's a tied match that
would be a tied match right there
absolutely wild that they even have a
chance after uh after the scores in the
first round
um that being said though this one does
look good for mike so maybe mike is
going to be the hero that secures the
victory for for edward jones in the end
yeah tough you can get some counter play
you can play something like queen f6
pretend you want to go after this king
like knight f4 ideas
but i think it is just pretending not
much more than pretending um
i'm gonna be tough to make make
something happen here for black this e
pawn just way too strong
okay rook c not a bad move at all hoping
to go c5 maybe lock this bishop out a
little bit but but again the e6 pawn
very very strong in this case and the
black king is looking a little bit airy
over here on g8 definitely
i like white in this case
um let's check back in though on this
board one we'll stick with this for a
little bit what did justinia end up
doing he did go queen h1 forcing knight
g1 then he comes up with knight g3 check
a sacrifice and takes takes and now
after king to f2 what's the idea maybe
he was hoping for a bishop c5 but the
king could actually
help out in the defense by capturing
some of these attackers
okay instead just king takes f7
and justini is content to just play the
position now
uh so white does need to do some work to
untangle here how can white free up some
of these pieces
queen f3 check is a start
um this king has to go somewhere maybe
it wants to run towards the queen side
no he steps back to g8 but i mean that
does just allow some more checks if
white is is interested
you can also just go like rook d1 here
put the rook on a square where it's
defended
threaten rook takes d6 and if the bishop
moves you have rook to d8
yeah i think that this is the move that
i would play rook to d1 just keeps
everything together
okay instead work to e1 is very similar
going for rook to e8
um
yeah very similar should be more or less
the same i think so rookie one good move
i approve and i think mcnick jm
is is going to be able to get it done
here going to be able to get it done
so justine getting two owed on board one
by uh
by m.c nick jm even though he was the
rating favorite by 300 points
not not a good result for justini but
luckily i think
uh the rest of the edward jones team did
get off to a good enough start to to
still secure the victory here despite
the
despite the hurdles
on board one by the way since we only
have five teams playing here tonight we
do have doherty playing against uh just
sort of the extra players
of course you have to field at least
four players to have a corporate chess
league team but a lot of these teams do
feel more more than that and we do have
a wonderful nick risco both tournament
director and player house player uh
defending the chess club's honor against
dardy
okay h6 by justini is going to prevent
the back rank mate the king does have a
flight square now but i wouldn't be
surprised if
things do
do go badly despite having this flight
square so the one thing you can't do is
go knight e2 you might want to go 92
attack this queen attack this knight on
g3 but then i believe bishop c5 is
actually a good move forces the king
away and then you can take on e1
so you cannot move this knight just yet
however
um let's see what what can you do you
can go ricky eight check
and then knight e2
no then there's queen f1 then there's
queen f1
yeah this is why i like this move rook
to d1 just a little bit better i wanted
to add this threat of rook takes d6 with
queen takes g3 to follow um
that i think was the the best way to
untangle now now you're going to have to
do a little bit more work to figure out
how you can get after this king maybe
maybe like rook e8
king h7
followed by like queen d3 check it's
going to force g6 and then you can try
and invade on the f7 square
probably that's good enough but
a little more complex than rick d1
gives justini maybe a little bit of a
hope
okay queen to a check i'm not gonna lie
i didn't even really realize that was
legal
uh now probably knight to f3
probably knight to f3 and maybe this is
just simple maybe knight f3 is just
simple the knight defends the rook the
queen's attacked you don't have the h2
square
and
is your queen just dying the queen might
just die
okay no knight f3 instead we get queen
f3 back
offering a repetition of
a single move not three fold repetition
by any means
but justini says no he wants to improve
maybe he found that knight f3 move was
worried that given a second chance his
opponent would improve
what's this this is bishop c5 bishop c5
wins a queen or at least a piece
this king is checkmated you have to
block somehow sacrifice one of these
pieces yeah knight e2 not the way to go
queen h2 very strong move to uh
to induce
wow and and queen e3 i don't think they
noticed no knight knight d4 didn't even
help knight d4 didn't help because the
score is guarded anyways
so that's a queen now for justine
linguini against all odds saves this
game secures the match victory for
edward jones fishers of men actually
also winning their game
so they do end up with a couple points
to spare uh
edward jones does that is
although it did look a little bit scary
there for for a moment
okay that's going to be an extra queen
now for black that should be good enough
to win this game you can go queen g2 you
can yeah go queen e5 you can do really
anything here and you're gonna be off to
a good start
uh with that there's just
three games remaining in the round it
looks like we have um fort dardy we have
i love legos two uh wrapping up here
against
dn274
um
and yeah my brain needed a moment to
figure out which way the pawns are going
this king has marched all the way from
the first rank to the eighth rank for
some reason i don't know why but it
seems to be
a pretty good position
okay just don't hang back rank me just
don't hang check me that's all you have
to do don't hang check me
don't play like rook here or something
oh my god that would be so sad
oh my goodness
oh my goodness
scary stuff scary stuff
okay rook b7 that does allow this check
but it doesn't hang the mate
but even still now after block we're
going to be able to pick up this pawn
and
[Music]
maybe we even want to go rook rook g2
okay rook d2 instead this is
uh this is practical you just want to
stop this pawn before it can advance any
further
okay knights
e5
i think that uh
i think that white is trying to play
just for checkmate here which i think is
the wrong idea
you just want to pick up that last pawn
of blacks and then just promote your
your your rook pawn that would be the
simple way to to try and convert this
checkmating with the rook and knight and
king it is possible to get some kind of
position like that
but it is tough okay and then white
didn't find you needed rook f5 there to
save your material instead black picks
up the knight
and now is in no danger of losing so i
love legos too winning on time actually
i forgot no increment no increment in
the corporate chess league so winning on
time is going to be good enough uh for i
love legos too by the way maquez did
draw this game against uh
nmc gin
and how did how did they end up on
uh actually that was the last game i was
keeping track of right
i think that was the last one
um so with that uh edward jones wins
their match against bayer enterprise
wins their match against ascension and
doherty does pick up a few points
against the house players
and i believe they get uh full marks for
the buy round although maybe they only
get 10 points i'm not sure on the format
on that one
but good round for edward jones good
good round for enterprise of course
those two teams always the teams to beat
in the corporate chess league here
and with that i think we are ready to
move on
to round number two so let's see what
kind of matchups we've got oh we do
we do have the almighty matchup we have
the edward jones versus enterprise
matchup of the century here in round two
i believe earlier in the season they did
play each other just once uh but if i
remember correctly edward jones i think
forfeited some points maybe i'm getting
my seasons confused uh either way i
think this is the first time in the
season we're seeing them in a fair fight
edward jones versus enterprise it's
always a blast to watch this one we'll
see who come out on top i believe edward
jones is missing their uh normal board
one in vishal bardwage instead it's
going to be justine linguini trying to
take out john boyer kamikaze knight
going to be a tough
uh a tough matchup there
but i think on the lower boards edward
jones might be able to score some points
alex curford remains one of the
strongest board threes in the corporate
chess league always able to score a lot
of points
and mike
uh rated 1380 gonna be a very strong
board for i think he almost doubles uh
enterprises board forward rating in
nirvan bungley so those lower boards are
where edward jones is known to score a
lot of their points gonna be tough for
for them vishal changed companies oh my
goodness no more vishal that is a huge
blow to edward jones's uh chess team
probably also just edward jones
corporation uh vishal seemed like a
great guy um and wow changed companies
is he going to play for a competitor i
wonder is he going to play for a
competitor and there you can actually
see
vishal i think second from the left
there
the normal board one for edward jones
has abandoned his team all for career
prospects absolutely ridiculous uh needs
to get his priorities straight corporate
chesley comes first corporate chesley
comes first how can you leave a winning
team like edward jones
uh oh well though uh edward jones of
course are reigning champions you saw
them there with uh the
champion board from the fall season
uh looking to defend their title here
today
and alex the edward jones captain of
course says he made him signed a a non
uh a non-competition agreement uh
non-compete agreement so we won't be
seeing vishal on any of the other teams
uh thankfully that's you know the
uh what do you call it the the silver
lining the silver lining for edward
jones they might not have a shawl but
nobody else can have them either
all right
so we're just waiting here for the
second round to get underway by the way
it's going to be ascension versus
doherty uh as the other matchup and
bayer is going to be getting the bye
round playing those house players
um and ascension darty i think it's
going to be a pretty competitive matchup
if i'm not mistaken ascension is going
to have the advantage on those top two
boards once again
but i love legos 2 is also a pretty
strong board 3 up against s gilmore 999
and actually ascension fielding a very
competitive team here tonight um they
very narrowly lost to enterprise in that
first round it came down to the final
two games both of which did go
enterprises way
um so ascension maybe the the dark horse
the dark horse to look out for maybe
they'll be the ones to finally dethrone
the uh previously dominant edward jones
and enterprise
maybe they will be the ones to look out
for i think they've also done well thus
far although maybe they had to deal with
some forfeits in the previous rounds
so they are definitely in the playoff
hunt
uh be on the lookout be on the lookout
for them
okay
well
and with that what'd you guys think of
this the spring chess classic that just
finished we had an absolutely riveting
playoff earlier here today between
ileana's nick and uh the wonderful sam
savion both of those players by the way
keep an eye on them keep an eye on them
their feed a rating is is getting up
there they might be the the next two
american players to cross that 2700
barrier
but without further ado we have liftoff
here let's take a look at some of these
games we've got let's see where are the
edward jones
uh
enterprise games at let's take a look
board one justinia linguine against
kamikaze knight we have a kings indian
defense bold choice by john boyer with
the black pieces bold choice
thus far justini is playing the way that
i do i love it
this is the
i guess classical or orthodox i'm not
sure uh exactly what they want to call
it a variation of the king's indian
defense this is the one where black gets
to have some fun try and checkmate white
you're going to see this f5 f4 kind of
stuff happening but in the meantime
white is going to be expanding over here
on the queen's side
and yeah this is exactly how i play
ah
no longer okay i play the old the olden
way with knight to e1 allowing me to
play f3 shore up my center and reroute
this knight towards the queen side
instead we get b4 ala vladimir kramnik
the bayonet attack
so what's the idea of b4 well in my
system i want to go
knight to e1 knight to d3 and play for
c5 sometimes i even do it as a sacrifice
b4 is a much more direct way of playing
for c5 this is still the key pawn break
the downside though black can
immediately challenge this pawn before
white gets the chance that's what we see
with a5 here so justini captures on a5
goes rookie one and bishop f1
and black for the moment is going to be
able to keep control over the c5 square
now i'm not really up to date on all the
big theory in these positions but
it looks like this has gone quite well
for black actually very solid control
over c5 i don't think this is really
what justine was hoping for out of the
opening here you really need to be going
for the c5 break you're going to be
playing the bayonet attack i believe
what normally happens here is after a5
in order to keep the pressure up you see
bishop a3 trying to to keep the pressure
on these dark squares after ba5 and b6
life is good life is good for for black
here
okay this bishop g4 move also very very
strange this is a great attacking piece
in the king's indian defense for uh
black also
i don't know if you can see the board
anymore hopefully you can
um
in the king's indian defense the light
squared bishop always a fantastic
attacking piece
so i don't love john's decision to put
it on g4 maybe he's like looking to to
trade it off for this night but this
bishop normally just belongs back here
on c8 allows white black to go f5 f4 g5
g4 and play for mate
instead this bishop's out on g4 now that
does connect black's major pieces but
black isn't really looking to play on
the queen's site you know that's where
white wants to be playing that's where
white wants the action to be black is
strong on the king's side uh there's a
common rule in chess you want to play
where your pawns point so black's pawns
pointing in this direction that's where
black wants to be playing
okay john does realize this and does
come out with f5 but i would rather have
this bishop back here on c8 sort of
lying in weight sitting in the weeds
waiting for its moment to to spring to
life to pounce to checkmate the white
king
instead out here on g4 just a little a
little strange in my opinion just a
little strange
uh h3 for example for
uh white not going to be a bad idea i
think h3 would make some sense
that being said i still absolutely love
black's position without the c5 break uh
white is is just going to be in big
trouble
big big trouble
okay
justine mulling it over trying to figure
out what to do
what to do about this pin he does end up
going h3
does end up going h3
yeah i'm trying to figure this out
myself with white and bishop takes f3 oh
i hate this move keep this bishop bishop
h5 was great you can keep the pin alive
and most importantly you can keep your
bishop alive
um
okay yeah john going for for a very
different position normally you want to
go you want to go f4 you want to go g5
h5 g4 and you want to play for mate
without the light squared bishop though
that does get a lot more tough so john
switches ideas takes on e4 and puts this
knight on f5 in instead he's just gonna
put this knight on d4
again white just doesn't have any play
on the queen side so no matter what
black does i'm not going to be too
unhappy with the position but i think
this playing for mate idea was still the
correct way to go here black could have
had a dominating position instead just
going to be comfortable just going to be
comfortable now for black
see what justine can do about it though
uh needs to find some way to get active
probably you want to stick this knight
onto b5 yeah i don't mind bishop d2
either uh sort of harassing this rook a
little bit so knight b5 will maybe want
to go a5 and just start to slowly battle
our way back into this game get some
kind of activity over here on the queen
side with this a5 brake
okay knight to c5 is a tempo move
it's tough to figure out where this
queen really belongs you can step back
to c2 but the knight to d4 is is really
gonna
ruin your day that's that's a day ruiner
also how's it going brian in the chat
thank you for joining us uh this of
course is the corporate chess league
where the best chess players in the st
louis corporations battle it out to uh
gain honor and glory for the most part
all right queen to g4 by justini this i
guess is
more or less the only square you can
make it to
uh with this knight on c5 now though
it's going to be tough to play knight b5
black is going to have pressure on this
a pawn
and without knight to b5 tough to see
where white is going to get active play
knight to b3 as well
attacks two pieces but rook a2 i think
does save the day
rook a2 should save the day here
what else maybe rook d1 but i would
rather play rook a2 okay
knight to e4 and
these are
big tactics big tactics
um i would have preferred to see just
rook to a2
black doesn't have to take on a1 by any
means and if i'm recapturing on d2 i
would rather do it with the rook than
knight instead
takes on a1 i don't know that this was
actually the right way to go
for for john now
now this bishop is going to be able to
improve to c3 and it's also going to be
able to stay alive which it definitely
was not going to be the case if the
knight captured okay he he might see
something concrete though knight to c2
hits the rook so we have to go rook to
c1
but this is not a good change in
structure for black once this b pawn
leaves now we're going to look at the c5
idea again
you know a second ago it felt like c5
was just never going to happen now all
of a sudden anything's back on the table
it's all back on the table
okay rook to c1 is played
and what to do for john
sort of feels like things are starting
to slip a little bit takes on a5 takes
on c2 what else
what else and how do you stop c5 i don't
think you do stop c5
oh no wait a second rook f4 rook f4
oh man the tactic at the end of the
tactic rook f4 is going to win a piece
here i i did not see this from afar i
did not see this one coming rook f4 just
attacks two things at the same time the
knight on d4 covers e2 no way for the
queen to move and defend the knight
and wow out of nowhere john boyer does
have a resource
does have a resource
to keep the lead and actually just get
an entirely winning position now
bad news bad news for justine linguini
and edward jones tactic comes out of
nowhere okay no what am i talking about
how did i miss queen g5 okay queen g5
saves the queen threatens on d8 and yeah
justine finds the only resource to to
save save the material
wow
queen g5 bad miss by me good find by
justine linguini though
although oh my god oh my god just queen
to e8 just queen to e8 and if you move
this knight bishop f6
if you go knight g3 bishop f6 traps the
queen
so i guess you have to come back to c3
and then you have the g3 square for the
queen
looks very suspicious looks very
suspicious maybe queen f8 was better to
pressure this f2 pawn then you can go
bishop f6 bishop h4
and
yeah that was probably close to winning
actually
um now you cannot play knight to g3 your
queen gets trapped
on g5 after not bishop f6 but actually
just h6
okay f3 instead okay that does still
allow you to have this g3 square
although now it
um
yeah still it still looks a little bit
scary so h6 there is queen g3
but uh definitely
playing with fire
playing with fire here
f3 is important though because we do
want to keep this diagonal locked down
oh my goodness rick takes f3 all the
tactics i can't see any tactics today i
just can't see any tactics okay if you
take this rook back
knight takes f3 um is a fork of the king
and the queen
and that's that's a sad story that's a
sad sad story
so on every move i have missed something
critically important
i think though that this one i'm not
missing anything that's an extra pawn
for john boyer should be a very very
good position once again all right
unless i'm i'm missing something again
this one should be working out should be
working out for john here
okay with that that's enough of this
game why don't we take a look at what's
going on on board two between fishers of
men and kenjalum
fisher's men with the white pieces
playing for edward jones
where they are behind in writing on
board one edward jones is ahead on
rating in on board two so this is where
they're really looking to score their
points
fisher's men does get this rook d7 move
looks like a clean uh extra two pawns
for white you might think that black has
some chances because the bishops are
opposite colors but with two pawns it's
normally always going to be enough in
this a pawn looks like it might not
survive the game as well looks like it
might not survive
especially here just bishop a4 picks up
the pawn
uh fisher's ben chooses to
simplify a little bit further with rook
to d7 instead i would prefer to take the
pawn but i do think that uh
white should be winning pretty much no
matter what in this position pretty much
no matter what white should always be
be doing quite quite well here
so it looks good for john on board one
uh looks good for enterprise aboard one
looks good for edward jones on board two
let's continue on down the line here see
how alex is doing up against 21
gigawatts and we are just in time i
think to see a nice little meet in two
combination knight f6 queen h5 that's
checkmate alex going to be picking up
this game
i'm going to be picking up picking up
this one knight f6 queen h queen h7
impossible stop
very importantly this rook on f1 does
cover the escape route defends this
knight after king to g7
um queen h6 is the only blocking move
and that is also going to be mate in one
so alex picks up a win for edward jones
on board three
last but not least we've got miquez
against nirvan on board four
and
yeah if i'm doing the math correctly i
think edward jones is the rating
favorite on the lower three boards so
john on board one definitely needs to
get it done for enterprise and then
enterprise also is going to be relying
on some upsets on these lower boards in
order to to win this match
okay here it looks like mikaez is way
out in the lead that white king just
does not have a lot of shelter it's
going to be in a lot of trouble there on
g1
all black needs to do is play f5 rook f6
rook g6 and that is a checkmate threat
so we'll see if miquez is familiar with
this rook lift idea it looks like it's
going to be really really strong here
but if you don't know this idea it might
be hard to come up with these moves
and mukesh just gives this check instead
but that's not really going to help
anything
it's not going to help much the king
just is going to shuffle back and forth
between the h file and the the g file
you really need the rook you need the
rook to get involved in order to
create more concrete threats here
so again f5 looks like the way to go f5
no time to take on d6 because i go rook
f6 rook g6 right away and that's just
going to be checkmate just immediately
going to be checkmate
can he find this f5 idea
no queen to f6 okay he takes it easy
just depends on f6
so i'm gonna go ahead and say i don't
think black needs necessarily to check
me white right away here to have a good
position
but given some time these these two
connected past puns over here they will
make their way down the board and if
that happens
you better look out better look out with
the black pieces those pawns could very
much become a danger uh if they start to
roll down the board
they start to to get rolling
black could be in trouble
okay
with that
let's check back in
looks like uh john did get that first
win uh for
uh enterprise and then what happened in
the fishers of men game if i can find
that
here it is still ongoing we've got this
opposite colored bishop end game now but
it's just way way way too many pawns the
bishop over here is able to stop the a
pawn but the h pawn on the total
opposite side of the board
no way uh
no way can black just keep everything
together here
just
not gonna happen
not gonna happen
okay bishop e2 i think maybe you could
even get away with h6 there
interestingly enough
you could even get away with playing h6
directly
yeah no black can stop this pawn but
it's as simple as bringing the king
playing a7 and ending the game
that's a game ender right there
that is a game ender
okay so that one
looks good for frank let's check back in
then on board one
and we have a french it looks like uh so
john gets a shot with the white pieces
now goes for this early f4
and
[Music]
okay and this b4 idea is interesting
gets rid of that c pawn black plays b5
oh and takes on c3
okay so john is playing a pawn sacrifice
here
and black does get this free pawn on c3
but in return loses a queen so i'm gonna
go ahead and say
good sacrifice pawn for a queen um seems
like john is is winning this one just
just out of the opening this time
tough tough situation
and looking at our standings there it
does look like darty only gets 10 points
for having the buy round
so half point buy for them meaning a
10-point buy
not not too bad not too shabby
okay knight d3 played
and yeah i think this might just be
it might just be resignation here by by
justine no coming back from that one
no coming back from that
okay let's see did fischer's men end up
securing that victory
looks
like they
did
looks like they did
meanwhile what's going on on this board
4 game looks like the white center fell
apart
and now finally we might see a rook lift
but again things moving sideways has not
been the strong point here tonight has
not been the strong point
so remains to be seen will rook takes be
b4 be found
b4b found
uh looks like black has the idea to just
make another queen you don't even really
need to here with all these major pieces
on the board in this white king with no
shelter
checkmate is just going to be
going to be coming with the current
material situation
okay queen d4 first also seems fine
again just we're taking here
check check and mate to follow
the old check checkmate
easy peasy
king g3 you can throw in queen f4 check
as well if you really really want to
if you really really wants
okay queen b4 not my favorite again
wanted to get these rooks involved so we
could checkmate the white king but
doesn't look like black is is running
much risk here
yeah just to confirm fisher's men did
win that first round
so with that i think the score is
uh two to one for edward jones so far
and assuming mike can win that position
that would be three to one after that
first round of play
so definitely we need to come back from
enterprise in round two
comeback is going to be needed and i
think
i believe justine linguini has already
resigned his game yeah so that's a quick
2-0 for john boyer nice little opening
trap there uh sticking this queen on b2
with nowhere to go just nowhere to go
absolutely nowhere to go so that brings
the score to 2-2 for edward jones versus
enterprise but again they are the rating
favorite
on all of the remaining boards
uh why don't we stick with alex this
game see what we've got going on here
from the start uh we had a french
sicilian
or an e6 sicilian i guess you would call
it
and
a little tactic here a little discovered
attack on this bishop on c4
um so black picked up a pawn early on
picked up a second pawn now with queen
to b4
up two pawns seems pretty good
in fact e5 might even be winning a piece
here we've got some fancy tactics knight
to d5 is your only idea to defend e7
although okay i guess this queen
technically defends
but after this i thought we would be
able to go knight takes d5 hitting the
queen if you take back i go rook to b1
the queen has to move again
and
maybe after queen c5 i even go knight b3
okay none of that fancy stuff um 21
gigawatts just trades just trades it off
so maybe he missed a missed a shot there
maybe rook to b1
somehow might have given black some more
difficulties in keeping everything
together
but after that alex does seem to be
simplifying a little bit
and maintaining a maintaining a material
edge
you would like to play d6 here maybe you
can get away with it you have to just
activate your pieces now once you take
some material and chests the the last
thing you want to do is get super greedy
go after more material you just want to
simplify you want to do what's called
consolidating you want to make sure that
you're surviving with your position
you're shoring up your weaknesses you're
getting your final pieces into the game
and once you do all that there's nothing
left but the extra material that you've
gained
nothing left but the extra material
okay knight f5 is is now looking a
little bit scary that's why i wanted to
play d6 last turn we really needed to
contest this knight f5 idea now after
knight f5 the queen moves this knight
can even jump into d6 maybe
looks slightly unclear but maybe this
knight can come to d6 maybe we can make
threats against the king
and maybe alex has has some worries
not quite so easy after all uh even
though he is up two full pawns
not quite as easy as you would hope
so with a win here
that would actually give enterprise the
temporary lead in the match maybe
permanently actually is that true did
because win that last game okay mike did
win his last game
so it is uh now three to two in edward
jones's favor
and
uh a win here for 21 gigawatts if he's
able to make something happen with his
active knight that would only level the
score that would only be good enough to
level the score
okay we get queen c5 queen c5 for alex
um hoping to activate this way get the
queen out of danger
if you go to knight d6 i guess what you
have to be worried about here is f6 by
the way there is queen takes d5 in the
position
um just to show you this little tactic
queen d5 queen d5 knight e7 check would
pick the queen back up but i'm not sure
it's actually in white's best interest
to do that you kind of need the queen on
the board to keep making some threats
okay i really don't like this knight e3
move played by white our knight was
super active here on f5 able to make a
ton of threats after knight e3 you make
a one move threat against the pawn but
black wanted to play bishop b7 anyways
connecting the rooks now uh and you've
made your knight just a simply a worst
piece uh honestly best move might just
be to bring the knight back to f5 the
knight was fantastic there it belongs on
f5 it should have stayed
on f5
instead we get rook a to c1 and alex is
now taking the opportunity to make some
sneaky threats of his own trying to set
up this battery
against this g2 pawn
and i think alex has done it he has
consolidated as we say now he just needs
to start rolling these pawns
and that will give his rook something to
do supporting the pawns from behind and
once those pawns get rolling then then
white is in in serious serious trouble
okay so looking very good for alex now
let's check back in on this game and
what on god's green earth has happened
here there's a pawn on h7 okay we'll
just take it take it back from the top
and we add another sicilian
um fishers of men gets castled and white
launches this attack on the king's side
leaves his own king in the center
and goes g6
wow okay takes h7 takes e6 white is just
destroying
white is just wait oh white was
destroying oh no
okay white was destroying but this is a
threat and after knight e6 simply queen
to d7
and kenjalin was worried about knight
takes f3 i think you can actually just
capture on f8 still
could have still just captured on f8
because it would have gained a tempo on
the black queen so knight f8 knight f3
does fork but after king d192 you just
take back on d7 take back on d7 you get
the queen back instead queen to g2 uh
saves the queen but loses the knight so
fishers of men was in real trouble just
getting destroyed out of the opening but
kendallum does not find the tactics to
to save his position now he's just down
a piece now the center is going to be
collapsing here um i don't know if you
can take this right away
but
black should be on the better side of
things just up a clean piece just going
to be up a clean piece here
is black still threats around his king
so not totally out of the woods yet
but fishers of men is is up a piece oh
wow he does go for bishop e4 okay i
guess
i don't think you can do this bishop g2
okay there was bishop g2 hitting the
rook on a8 you can take on e3 but take
take and then bishop a8 and set after
castle castles uh black is just winning
actually
a second piece now uh
so no queens on the board a second piece
for black
no worries at all now for fishers and
men he should be able to win this game
as well
and if fishers of men and alex both win
out
um then that's a match victory for
edward jones so this is a huge huge game
huge huge game
um that means this result is all the
more important and it looks like alex
does have things under control he
managed to take the queens off he can
now actually just go ahead and take on
e5 winning a third pawn
defending the bishop with the rook
uh so looking very very nice here for
alex as well up three full pawns those
queen side pawns will eventually get
rolling down the board
and white will
will most likely lose this one
most likely
okay there's a result up here uh fishers
of men actually just wins by resignation
looks like a rook was hung somehow
ah yeah the shirt came to g1
and then
uh knight to c6 okay was very very
sneaky removing the defender from e2
white had to retreat along the file
after rook to c7 simply check and take
and after king h7 kendalum had had
enough
so what's the score after that it looks
like edward jones is up by two
so yeah enterprise would need to win on
the remaining two games in order to tie
the match i don't think they're going to
be able to do that though
don't think it's going to happen
especially with this position for alex
this one i don't want to say it's
unlosable but it's close it's close
close to unlosable for alex here
okay we had bishop takes e4 threatening
the rook knight f2 defends the rook
probably we're just going to see a trade
by alex and then of course what i'm
gonna recommend just just move one of
the pawns in front of your king just to
make sure you're never getting back
ranked mated and then you you really
can't lose this game uh once once h6
appears on the board then i i am gonna
say it that it actually is
unlosable for for alex
meanwhile what's the situation on that
board four ooh looks like the the news
is even worse miquez has already won
by checkmate and what a checkmate it is
look at that the knight delivering mate
to the king on on e8
and with that edward jones i believe
just uh strictly secures match victory
there
maybe i can help out here and update
some of our scores
um two points there
let's see fishers of men i believe also
goes two and oh
alex um still in progress in miquez
going 2-0 as well that's going to be
enough for edward jones to win the match
so with this match decided why don't we
take a look at what's going on in some
of the other remaining games
we've got uh oak ave against ina de cava
uh for ascension uh versus darty oak ave
up to a one point lead let's see what's
going on in the other boards we had s
gilmore against i love legos two
so i love legos two up one nothing over
there so that's one to one for ascension
doherty
um let's see if i can find any of the
other games okav
no that was the first game for oak ave
not the second one
okay what else is going on we've got
frank tan against c cell looks like
frank tan won two to zero so that gives
ascension a two point lead and then
maurice
uh splits one to one
so with that uh it looks like doherty
would need to
win both of the remaining games in order
to
tie this match so
ascension only needs a half point on
these remaining boards let's take a look
at what's actually going on in the games
very strange position here
for uh inadequate
looks like oak avez is on the better
side of things i just did a quick count
looks like black is up
up some number of pieces now after c4
you don't really want to take bishop
takes c4 is going to be discovered check
hits the queen as well big danger knight
to c3 that just loses the queen as well
okay i'm going to win this other second
game and secure match victory for
ascension as well
okay so with that the matches i believe
have been all but decided assuming oak
ave wins
if that game does go his way then it
will be edward jones and ascension
winning in this round two pretty close
matches today though pretty close
matches uh scary stuff for for everybody
involved why don't we stick with alex
then since we've seen much of this game
okay i lied i don't want to stick with
alex much longer i'm expecting
resignation here by gigawatts and that
will allow alex to uh win all four of
his games today impressive showing by
alex
um i think the only other player with a
perfect record is kamikaze knight john
boyer so impressive stuff there
impressive stuff
okay it looks like um chickawatts will
go for stalemate however he will be
denied h6 check g5 check forces the king
out of his little hidey hole here and
once the king ends up behind these pawns
much tougher to to stalemate much
tougher to get stalemate
maybe he'll try to be clever go rick at
b3
no no cleverness needed just g5
and oh i forgot that king h5 was legal
but
this won't help
this is a nice checkmate if uh alex can
find it bring the bishop back to e8
always a pleasure
in that fishers of men game
knight g6 would be mates instead of
taking the queen
oh my goodness you're absolutely right
you're absolutely right
um so here if we go knight f8 um and
knight f3 check king d1
and if take on d2 there's even better
than taking the queen you can play
knight g6
checkmate
pretty convincing pretty convincing
um so yeah knight takes f8 big miss by
kendall that could have very much
changed the outcome of that game alex
does win goes for checkmate from the
front with the bishop rather than at the
back
you know matter of preference i guess i
would have liked to see bishop e8 check
me but bishop takes g4 checkmate not bad
in its own right
okay with that i think we just have a
couple games remaining we have uh iana
dekeva holding on
for dear life against oak ave okav up a
veritable army against inadequate but
fighting nonetheless although running
out of time
running out of time as well and i think
with this
in three more seconds it'll be official
that ascension has secured match victory
and it is official oak ave winning the
match for ascension and that just leaves
us with
uh i love legos 2 against s gilmore
and this position looks kind of crazy
but black has more rooks so at the end
of the day the number of rooks
will i think end up making a difference
here
should be good enough for gilmore to
score a point
um so i wonder how this is going to
impact our overall standings
um i think with a victory here for
gilmore that puts one more point up for
ascension
and they will gain 20 points for the
match victory so actually ascension
gonna score more points than enterprise
here tonight despite losing their
head-to-head matchup uh interesting
interesting turn of events
uh kind of kind of strange turn of
events lose the head-to-head matchup but
still score more points than them
uh edward jones of course is gonna walk
away the big winner i don't even think
yeah they're gonna get 20 points on top
of the 38 points that they already have
for winning that second match so
huge huge day for edward jones extending
their lead
uh already putting up a respectable
score as well
they did put up quite a fight against
ascension there but those lower boards i
think were where
where they struggled also sea cell had a
tough day on board one some tough
competition
for sure some very tough competition
okay g6 played by gilmore gets out of
the check
okay rook back to b1
um i love legos too a little bit
disjointed with all the pieces trying to
keep it all together going to be very
difficult very very difficult to achieve
strike has to go to a1 if it wants to
keep defending this bishop and then
after take
take
and rook to d1 whoops don't look at that
rook to d1 then this bishop's pinned you
have to go bishop b2 we can simplify
even further
and it's going to be an extra exchange
for
uh for gilmore for s gilmore
so the players are for once actually
following the moves that i'm saying i'm
kind of crazy okay we get a little
intermezzo here takes on g6 takes on g6
doesn't hurt anything
um just e6 okay this is gonna let me
take uh it's gonna let me take a piece
and i think it's a piece that should be
captured okay
uh uh gilmore not perturbed by the
sudden sacrifice
does go ahead and and captures that
piece yeah the king is going to actually
be in time now
to blockade this pawn and an extra rook
is going to be an extra rook
king f6 just king f8 is simple enough
and king e8 will
stop that pawn in its tracks
this is officially our final game uh
remaining by the way
last one of the night here
takes on g2
e-pawn's not going anywhere
we do collect it now and we will not see
king and rock mate instead black
runs the king all the way over the queen
side picks up those last remaining pawns
and
will now promote the b-pawn
bring that queen over to h1
and that is
checkmates
there it is black winds
okay with that that is it for us here
tonight that is the final game of the
corporate chess league tonight lots of
fun tonight these games are always a lot
of fun to cover um tough day for
actually not really a tough day for
anybody everybody put up good fights
today everybody scored at least some
points bayer getting that buy round on
the last round will also get 10 extra
points from those standings that you
just saw
um edward jones definitely going to be
the big winners today winning both of
their games uh or both of their matches
is going to give them a huge bump in the
uh grand prix standings
so congratulations to them
congratulations to everybody on some
really well played games tonight i had a
lot of fun covering these things
um if you guys learn anything from
tonight remember that rooks and queens
can move sideways i think there are
about 10 tactics that were missed
because nobody sees that pieces move
sideways i myself continue to struggle
with that as as well so that's my big
takeaway for tonight
okay as always thank you all so much for
joining me here tonight my name is caleb
denby this has been the corporate chess
league spring season please tune in uh
not next thursday but thursday after for
the next round of the corporate chess
league we'll be here with a lot more fun
a lot more action
see you next time
[Music]
you